mac brown back here on the rich eisen
show how you been coach brown i'm great
rich how are you i'm doing great what a
big week it is on campus there huh
yeah it is i'm so proud of our
basketball team and hubert and
basketball is so different than football
rich here we are at 10 and 5 at
mid-season in the acc and struggling and
people are all mad and now we've got a
chance to win the national championship
so just proud that hubert's turned it
around and stayed so positive and
they're they're playing at the highest
level all year so it's going to be an
exciting weekend now when you first got
to campus there the coach was dean smith
correct when you first got there yes i
had coached for nine years wow
so
what was uh that like when you got
because you were your young coach just
getting started out you know fresh from
tulane if i'm not mistaken right and
then there's dean smith who's in charge
of the basketball program on campus what
was that like for you mac brown rich it
was great and he was a mentor to me and
he was he was always so direct
and i just loved it he i laughed with
the media one day and we're walking off
he said don't they're not your friends
don't don't laugh with them
that's just not smart
i said yes sir
yes sir whatever you think and then i
had a player get in trouble once and i
went over and i said coach what coach
smith what would you do and he said
i've got 13 coaches for 13 players
you got 120 players and nine coaches i
wouldn't coach football if i was you
it's impossible to keep up with all this
guy so he he he was even saying that to
you huh
yeah he was wonderful and
and and he was so good at what he did
and so direct and he taught me so much
and it was a lot of fun and then i had
coach guthrie
after that for his three years and then
i had roy williams was here as an
assistant a volunteer assistant when i
first got here
and then roy went to kansas and came
back and of course i had him
the last couple of years and and i
remember hubert here before and then i
knew hubert really well with the espn so
it's just fun to to to watch their
success i'm sitting in my office and
i've got a a picture with me and coach
smith me and coach williams and now me
and hubert so it's amazing oh it's it's
been the i need to get coach guthrie's
up there but we've got the uh we've got
the full gamut yeah because again you
were you know um
in your first year at carolina that was
hubert's too right as a player he was a
freshman when you were on campus there
so it was so much fun to watch him and
his story is so good he's overcome so
much
even coach smith telling him i don't
think you ought to come here you you
can't play here
and
and then coach williams talking coach
smith into taking him and then he's one
of the all-time greats here the nba
great too and
um so he's just that's who he is he he
uh he takes negatives and turns him into
positives he uh
he's a guy that uh
is going to lift everybody up around him
with a smile and and um
one of the things he and i talked about
before he started is you got to be you
you're following all these legends but
you got to be you
and i'm so proud of him he is being
hubert davis that's just that's what's
gotten us
uh to this point where we are in the
final four mac brown head coach of north
carolina football joining us here on the
rich eisen show
again on a big week on campus there uh
in north carolina and that's also
because you had your pro day
um how did that one work for you what is
your pro day like how do you how do you
approach a pro day
mac brown
pro day rich for us is uh
an opportunity for all the guys that did
not go to the combine to have their
combine
and the second thing is if our guys we
had five go to the combine
if they didn't do something
or if they didn't do something well it's
an opportunity for them to to redo it
or or do it here for the first time and
and help their stock in the draft
we had all 32 teams represented
represented
they were
they were excited we've got coach daryl
moody who is a 19-year nfl scout that
handles them while they're on campus
we had the nfl network here we had acc
network here
so it's a big deal
and and what we want to do is make sure
that the scouts get the the best
uh evaluation that they can of our guys
and give our guys opportunity to improve
their stock for the draft
and uh that's what our day is about so
it's really about being transparent
and everybody having a chance to
evaluate everybody and and it's um even
more important after covid because so
many guys
didn't get true evaluations in that
couple of years for the nfl
i'm sure it hurts some of them so so now
we we feel like this is uh
this is a great opportunity for them to
show who they are so you know and of
course pro days are different mac brown
when you've got um a highly touted
quarterback prospect uh in the draft on
your team at your pro day it might uh
bring a little bit more uh bees to the
hive right um so
what was sam howell's pro day like from
your
perspective sam did a lot of things at
the combine he had a lot of interviews
there
what he did
last monday was throw the ball
and he brought in
ryan switzer who was a great player here
in the past that's looking for a home
because
he's in between teams right now and he
brought a couple of guys in from
charlotte that he'd been throwing with
and i thought he really put on a show
i'm sure i'm prejudiced i wanted it to
be good
but if i was a pro scout standing there
watching it and and the evaluations that
i got from the pro scouts that did watch
him
uh he was very accurate he was all over
it um
and i thought it was good and will
really help us start so but you know the
conversation about stock and and you
know you don't hear his name very much
even in the first three that are
mentioned um certainly in what i do for
a living i constantly hear
scouts talk about it you know and you
you hear about pickett's name you hear
about uh matt corral's name you also
hear malik willis name from from liberty
how did you you know you pound the table
for sam howell right here how does he
stack up why why do you think his name
is not thrown into this mix as much as
we hear
well rich we weren't as good we lose uh
two great receivers to the nfl two years
ago we lose two outstanding running
backs all four of them played a lot
and and started
so we weren't as good and i felt like we
had some entitlement and i don't think
we helped him as much as we should have
but
he's tough
he ran the ball more because we didn't
protect as well
uh he's uh
he's who he is he he didn't get hurt for
three years he
led our team for three years
uh we're in the mix with a lot of
recruits rich and last year we were had
the eighth best recruiting class in the
country
largely because sam howell came here he
changed the narrative he was the best
player in the state he decides to come
other other kids want to come
and i think pro scouts are going to see
that and and you and i have been doing
this a long time and one thing we know
about the draft is about the time you
think something's a hundred percent it's
not
so
it just takes one team
that has interest that's not going to
tell the others because they do not want
the other people interested
to slip in there and decide they want
him and take him and and that's what i'm
thinking that's what i'm hoping happens
all right so
uh
shoot you know you just you just cur you
just stomped on my next question was
which teams were interested in him so
you
well one thing you're not going to get
with teams in the draft is honesty and
pre-draft
but what about with you i mean when
you're standing on the side and i'm sure
people are button holding you or you're
going up to say hello and
i mean what do you what what are you
hearing uh about him or the questions
that you're getting in regards to sam
that you can share we hear good things
the the
two things would be his height
and there's a lot of guys that aren't
really tall that are playing and playing
well right now and the uh the second
thing is why didn't we play better i
mean and that's not on him that's on us
and and i take responsibility for that
as much as anybody so
i sure wish we had him back
i wish that was the deal but
but we don't and uh
so i feel good
i know who else you want to pound the
table for because uh we're all talking
about your quarterback who else yeah
well there's some other guys that uh ty
chandler came in here from tennessee and
he gained a thousand yards as a running
back and he became a captain as a grad
transfer which is an
a really unique feat
that the the players would trust him
so so i think that
that's really cool uh joshua zudu is a
guy that they feel like a really good
offensive lineman that we had and we've
got some other offensive linemen they're
talking about as well
um
a guy that didn't get to work out as
much money
uh money
is a guy that we feel like is a really
good player and that's jeremiah gimmel
at linebacker but he hurt his shoulder
some in the bowl game
so he'll be limited here a little bit
but we've we've told them um
rich i think the most important thing
and i told the scouts this and the
players we had 10 guys work out monday
all of them have their degree
and
not many people are gonna make pro
football teams
and if you do you're probably the the
average age might be two to three years
so get your degree
plan for life after football if you get
some pro football in there great good
for you
but not many people are going to make a
great living in pro football and if you
do
if you have 10 years and you get out and
you're
you're 30 years old
31 years old you got the rest your life
to do something so
we try to get our guys prepared for life
after and then if you can play some on
the way good for you mac brown here on
the rich eisen show head coach of north
carolina tar heel football how has nil
changed your world
coach
rich
my wife's smarter than i am and sally
told me when i was griping about nil
early that you know artists in college
get to sell their art
musicians get to go play at bars and
and concerts and make money so why
shouldn't football players or athletes
be able to to make money off their name
image and likeness so i got that
what we don't have is we don't have
guard rails
nfl's got more guardrails and guidelines
than we do so
i'm all for it i like the fact guys can
make some money
but we don't even have a salary cap
i mean so we we need to learn from the
nfl they've got more guidelines than we
do so i hate the fact that nio was
thrown on all athletics directors and
coaches
without guidelines so then what
guidelines would you want
i think we've got to figure out
uh what we can do to make sure that that
some of the the word i think that that's
public is not true when they're talking
about millions and millions of dollars
i i don't think that stuff's really
happening like people are saying it
but i think what we should do is try to
help all the young people get some money
um i thought maybe there's a 50 000
bonus when you graduate
um
maybe there's group licensing because
these are team sports they're it still
was about amateurism and now we're not
we're
we're we're inching closer to pro
football
with college sports and and that's just
what what we're doing
um so it's a it's a difficult thing same
thing with a transfer portal i think we
can put more guidelines on it about when
and how and
and and but we're we're putting
maybe too much money in some young
people's pockets
more than they're ready to handle we're
making them be adults sooner than they
have in the past with paying taxes and
having agents and
and a lot of different decisions that
are coming earlier than some would like
um
and at the same time we're we're
some young guys get too much money and i
see one the other day that buys him some
crocs for 250 dollars and i said why
would you do that he said i can
um so
we've got to do a better job of making
sure that we're
talking to them about how to handle
their money
and how to save their money
and and
how to make sure that they have money
moving forward because if a guy makes
fifty thousand dollars off an nil deal
that may be the most money he ever makes
in his life if he doesn't finish his
degree so
i hate right now rich that we're talking
more about nl deals than we are your
your degree and
what you're going to do because your
money's going to come afterwards for the
large majority of these kids your your
money's not going to come up front
and we've told them it's really about
your ball not your brand because if
you're not playing great ball they're
not going to pay you
and and they say it's uh you can't be
paid for your ball well
that's what the the supporters are going
to pay for so
we can say what we want but those are
the facts yeah sure your name image and
likeness is enhanced by how good you are
uh at your craft you know i i understand
that are are our schools
in recruiting
based on your knowledge um
just saying you come here you will make
this much in nil like making that part
of the recruiting process from what
you're doing yes rich there's always
been cheating and that's cheating you
can't just say that but people are i've
had kids come in my office and say if
you'll give me this much money i'll come
here and i said well who has offered you
this and they'll tell me the schools and
i said are there any guidelines no
have they told you you have to do
anything for it no
so there there but there's always
there's cheating in every business i
mean that's the way it is
what i think we need is to start having
contracts
we're we're being more like the nfl i
think it's unfair for a young guy to
hear he's going to make 50 000 and then
he gets to the school and they say no
you misunderstood
so let's sign contracts
let's have nil contracts where
uh and they're going to start putting in
there you got to go to the bowl game you
can't opt out of the season you can't
[ __ ] out you can't get a dui you can't
get arrested you can't quit the team
but i think it's as we get more
like the nfl we're going to see people
that are demanding contracts and i think
that's fair
because i'm afraid we're
in the early stages of this and we're
all trying to figure out how to navigate
it
and i'm afraid there's going to be some
families and some students that are lied
to that think they're going to get a lot
of money and then they're not going to
get it when they get there mac brown
here on the rich eisen show from north
carolina football couple minutes left
with you i'd love to pick your brain
going down memory lane what was you know
you just had your pro day for sam howell
what was vince young's pro day like back
in the day at texas
vince was so good but richard was the
same stuff that can he throw can he will
he stay healthy
he was in a
spread offense will that relate to the
nfl
and then it got to be um
he and matt leinard were the two that
everybody was talking about at the time
and and then the coaches that uh the
titans were usc coaches and they might
want liner and then they dot vince
because the owner and so draft is always
crazy
it's just crazy so i've told guys have
absolutely no expectations in the draft
don't have a big party have your party
after you're drafted don't spend your
money because it's not yours till you
make the team
uh and then after that
start back on life and and get it headed
back in the right direction have you
spoken events lately do you know what's
going on with him at all yes he's doing
great he finished school he still works
at the university of texas he's got a
lot of
businesses going on i probably
touch base with vince
two or three times a month so i'm really
really proud of what he's doing we have
a charity
with uh jack ingram and matthew
mcconaughey in a in a couple of weeks
here
end of april and vince is going to be
there and play a little golf he's
playing more golf so i used to be able
to beat him i couldn't
uh he couldn't find the ball he'd hit it
so far
but from what i've hearing from him and
what i see on twitter i think i've got
my hands full
i like him i'm back to a full-time job
now and he's not
what a night that was in the rose bowl
not talking about the year after against
my alma mater i'm talking about that
night against usc were you
were you i've never asked you this
question were you surprised reggie bush
wasn't in on that last play for usc i
really wasn't because the the uh lindell
white had made all the yards
he had 125 yards that night reggie had
one run
so it was and it was a power play that
had killed us all night so
a lot of people were so critical of of
pete
we thought lindell was going to get the
ball we thought it would be a power play
and we put all 11 on the line of
scrimmage and i remember gene chizick
the defensive coordinator who's here
with us now said what if they throw it i
said congratulations they're going to
win a national championship
but
we're going to stop lindell white from
making two yards yeah but i mean reggie
what happened reggie wouldn't have put
something in your mind like something's
up or he wouldn't that that's the whole
that's that that's the the old saw here
is that at least he would have
required some of your attention you know
that's right i don't think so i think if
they when you're fourth and one fourth
and one and a half
and they'd been running it right down
our throat and we couldn't stop the big
guy
um
i think reggie would have been like the
pass
if they pitch it to reggie wide
congratulate them and let's go home
but but we thought
they would take it and run it down our
throat
and and we thought that's what they
should do because they'd been doing that
all night
mac brown what a great chat this was um
and i greatly appreciate it i look
forward to the next time already um
let's let's connect thanks again thank
rich appreciate you having me on anytime
that's mac brown head coach of north
carolina football for a second time
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here